lionel jospin cliquer sur la touche
multimédia le premier ministre a annoncé
hier un plan d'action pour faire
rattraper à la france son retard en
matière d'équipements informatiques
un plan qui passe aussi par un renouveau
du minitel qui pourrait s'ouvrir à
internet explications patricia www
charles holley le minitel vous
connaissez vous êtes 15 millions à
l'utiliser en france internet vous êtes
des pionniers 500 mille d'entre nous
seulement ils ont accès d'où l'idée de
france telecom d'utiliser un matériel
familier pour vous permettre de
participer à cette révolution du savoir
nous préparons depuis plusieurs mois
avait que deux grands groupes
industriels français groupe alcatel le
groupe matra un appareil minitel
internet permettant d'accéder à la fois
haut de gamme d'informations à la 1098
un nouveau minitel vous proposera doc
l'accès à internet
son coût entre 2 et 3000 francs son
intérêt il sera moins cher qu'un micro
ordinateurs sa limite
le nouvel appareil n'offrira ni le
traitement de texte ni la lecture des cd
rom mais c'est là déjà un événement dans
la course impitoyable que se livrent les
industriels sur un plan mondial
car tout est encore envisageable l'accès
internet fournit actuellement par les
ordinateurs vous sera également proposée
demain sur vos écrans de télévision la
multiplicité des terminaux de lecture
aura au moins deux conséquences
la possibilité pour vous de choisir et
la baisse des prix inéluctable